Buenas tardes Richie hizo un axia
convertido hoy en el Primer Ministro
británico más joven de la historia con
apenas 42 años y como lo mencionabas el
primero de una minoría étnica nació aquí
en Inglaterra pero sus padres provienen
de la India definitivamente en ese corto
mensaje que escuchamos de richy sunat
desde la sede del partido conservador
aquí en el centro de Londres que duró
apenas un minuto y 24 segundos Richie
hizo una presentó Cuál será la prioridad
de su gobierno que iniciará en las
próximas horas y se puede recibir en una
recuperar la economía Richi es una
advirtió que se viene en tiempos
difíciles para el país Por eso hay que
estar preparado y Está tratando de dar
un mensaje de estabilidad a los mercados
a los inversionistas pero también al
país recordemos que la mayoría de la
población no tuvo la posibilidad de
elegir a Richi es una pero lo que espera
la gente es que los conservadores dejen
sus disputas internas a un lado Entonces
el nuevo Primer Ministro empiece a
gobernar para la gente las prioridades
las urgencias de la población Richi es
una acá ha dicho como lo hemos escuchado
que ser elegido Primer Ministro ha sido
el gran honor de su vida y directamente
un mensaje podría interpretarse a Boris
Johnson ha dicho que el liderará y
gobernará con humildad y además lo hará
con los más altos estándares éticos
Bueno y qué falta para que es una acceda
ratificado en este cargo
ya hemos visto que el partido
conservador lo ha elegido por unanimidad
ahora para que sea oficial que pueda
empezar a funcionar desde el 10 de Down
Street debe reunirse con el Rey Carlos
III eso se espera que sea probablemente
mañana Aunque debe ser confirmado se
sabe que el Rey Carlos está regresando a
Londres y posiblemente mañana desde el
Palacio de buckingham se reunirá
inicialmente con listas le aceptará la
renuncia se espera que ella dio un
discurso de despedida en la puerta de
Downey Street luego vaya al palacio de
buckingham a oficializar su renuncia
ante el Rey Carlos III y luego El
Monarca recibirá a richizunak y le
pedirá que en su nombre conforme un
nuevo gobierno y luego Richi snack
viajará de regreso a Downey Street y
empezará el tercer gobierno conservador
en este año ya también se Estaba
preparando la transición entre el equipo
de listras y el de es una esperaremos
también que una vez ya haya llegado
oficialmente ha dado un instruido
empiecen a anunciarse los cambios en el
gabinete